the thing that has kept me in a very
strong position from the earliest wine
videos i made to what i'm gonna do
tomorrow
is
i have never
talked about something i don't know
ever first of all it's a real pleasure
um you know i think
content creation
and all of you are in it so a lot of
this stuff will make sense but i think
the first thing that i think about
always
is self-awareness
i think the biggest issue for content
creators
is them being inspired by someone else
and then them subconsciously not even
consciously subconsciously trying to be
like that person
which is an incredibly difficult task
because every one of us in this room me
included
have strength and weaknesses in their
ability to create content
so
i think there's a couple things to think
about one
your own self-awareness of what you're
good at
for example i'll give you one
i think the concept of
writing content is like forgotten in a
visual world yet i can tell you
that some of my written content on
linkedin
is dramatically more profound and does
well than my clips on tiktok or
instagram and there may be people in
this room whose strongest method of
communication is actually in written
form yet
the push towards short form video or
images
make them work on that when they're
deviating from a strength
so i think first and foremost what i
think about is a couple things
and they're all in the form of
transparency and self-awareness one
what are you best at communicating is it
audio video
written form two
the thing that has kept me in a very
strong position from the earliest wine
videos i made to what i'm gonna do
tomorrow
is
i have never
talked about something i don't know
ever i think when you're a content
creator you feel pressure to output
and when you feel pressure to output
you can get very caught to start talking
or creating around something you may not
fully understand a lot of people come
and go and there's some very clear
truths to having success and i think
it's one understanding your format while
still trying to challenge yourself
you may be better at writing
it's still good to try to be better at
video
but it's not
crippling yourself and thinking you can
only be successful if you do video
two
do not deviate from your knowledge
now that doesn't mean going like look at
me i'm talking about nfts i spent 100
hours of research before i made my first
video
but
putting in the work to be able to talk
about something new is very important
the quickest way i've seen people lose
is by being too quick to talk about
things they don't know
very important
number three
a very big thing for everybody to keep
in mind here
do not fall in love with the platform
that got you there
a very big thing that i've seen
consistent in the last 15 years is
twitter was your strong platform here
came instagram and you didn't want
instagram to become big because you
didn't want to start over and build up
your following count so many and this is
going to make sense for all of you
so many leaders on instagram made a huge
mistake by not adopting tick tock right
they didn't want to because they had all
their followers
constant mistake
being too romantic about platform and
not adjusting to where the attention is
actually going
those are some themes that i would give
a lot of thought
[Music]
you know
the way you do it
is a couple different ways one i think
that a lot of people get hurt
by the ideology of perfection so i think
one of the reasons long before i had
drock or a team
i was able to buy myself while running
businesses
be active on every platform is because i
didn't ideologically
think about every single piece of
content
i think when you're trying to make every
piece perfect for yourself
perfection is usually just another word
for insecurity
you know everyone's overthinking it and
so one it's to feel comfortable with
that number two
is
to
be okay with not being on six platforms
you know i think sometimes we feel too
much pressure to be everywhere i talk
about it like be everywhere post a lot
a lot of people can't manage that and
that's okay
i believe it has to do with
insecurity of success of the piece of
content
the biggest reason people didn't go to
tick tock when they were winning on
instagram was they didn't have the
humility and the self-confidence to not
be successful on tick-tock
immediately so i think the biggest
reason people don't produce
is more of a mental game then it's not
hard to produce content for six
platforms it's really not
you can do it
it's that people fear
lack of success in numbers from a vanity
standpoint which stopped them from
actually doing it
so i think humility
humility is one of the true superpowers
of a scaled influencer or content
creator being okay with starting at zero
or being okay if the content's not doing
great
i'll give you another i mean for example
with me on tick tock even though i know
it's the most important platform i don't
have the time to produce original tick
tocks so i know my post produced content
doesn't maximize my ability to win on
tick tock but i'd rather still put out
stuff and get what i can
than be insecure that i'm only getting
50 000 views on a tick tock when i have
13 million followers that doesn't
register to me as a negative for too
many people it does register as a
negative
the case globally
it's a huge mistake
it tick-tock is eating up the attention
of the consumer by the second to to be a
content creator
like like to be in this room
and to not be producing content for tick
tock
is virtually unacceptable
i mean if you're a content producer
that's just a cr especially all the
different ways that tik tok now makes it
easy to make content voice-overs image
like there's it's
you're
you're
also making a very important mistake if
you're not doing it tick-tock
is based on the interest graph
not on the social graph
what i mean by that is as many of you
know
tick tock
puts content in front of you based on
what you're interested in not who you
follow
this is a very important insight for
everybody here as ai and algorithms
continue to increase that is a much
stickier
way of doing content than following
people
by not making tick tocks right now
you're not getting the practice of
understanding the interest craft which
would 100
going to be the way the next platform is
built and so you're not getting
accustomed to that format
which is almost like not running on a
treadmill before you have to run a
marathon
so
another reason tic tocs incredibly
important is it's prepping you for the
next iteration and by not doing it
you're getting even further behind as a
content creator
because your brain starts going into
interest graph creation
which is very important so when tick
tock was first popping
and i was making content
because i was making content when it was
musically before even the tick tock
acquisition
a lot of people were like what are you
doing this is for 13 year old girls
dancing and i'm like it's not it is now
but facebook was only for college kids
and instagram was just for photographers
platforms evolve
i think that yes it's important to be
contextual to the platform but not at
the expense
of your authenticity so i'd rather you
deliver the way you would deliver on
twitter and linkedin on tiktok and let
the chips fall where they may
than for you to not be who you are
at the same token
there is very much creative ways to
deliver serious information
on tick tock and i think
there are
countless examples of that
um and so i i think that yes i think you
should be contextual to a platform but
not at the expense of the content
you don't have to dumb it down
you have to make it contextual to
tik-tok
to do it
diversifying
your income streams is always a good
strategy
is always a good stress yeah of course
now
having the capacity or back to some of
the subjects that you just mentioned
some individuals here
content is more conducive to other
revenue streams if you've got a health
and wellness
platform it's easier for you to sell a
health and wellness product than let's
say being a doctor like but subscription
products of premium content is always in
play for people that i think a lot of
people don't
think about instantaneously
but yeah i mean
creating as many revenue streams as
possible is always a good idea
the problem is it's back to content and
platform you have to actually be decent
at it
like if you're going to sell a product
the product needs to be good or you're
not going to have repeat business and
that's not a viable business so i think
you know we started with this and i'll
bring it up again with revenue
uh self-awareness is very important
you know if you don't have any passion
for creating a product
well then it's probably a bad idea to
create a product
and so
i think um
but but yes i mean i think
relying on brand deals
is fine because there's so many
businesses and they'll
potentially always be opportunities but
the more you can control it
the more interesting it is which is why
i think so many creators eventually go
to their own product one of the things
as creators we think about is how do we
sustain for a long period of time
because people may get bored there's
many different ways to talk about this
first of all
i once took
a
two and a half year gap of producing any
content
two and a half years
so for five years i did wine content
from 2006 to 2011
and then it and then in 2014 i started
the askgaryvee show that's a long gap so
i think a lot of times we beat each
other up you beat yourself up for not
producing content
i'm
potentially one of the most prolific
content creators of the last decade and
i once took almost three years where i
made almost no content
so i hope that gives everyone a sense of
relief that if you have a bad week or
even a bad month it doesn't mean the end
of your
content career that's number one number
two
notice what i came back and did after
five years of doing wine content and not
doing content for three years the
content pillar that i decided to do was
a q a format
why did i do that because i needed the
audience to be a contributor to the
content creation i think one of the
great mistakes that a lot of people make
is they don't incorporate their audience
as a potential starter to creative
it is an amazing
training wheels setup
chess move putting you halfway home
incorporating your audience
to being
a starting point to more content is
something more people need to do
q and a's
answering questions interactions
[Music]
and then finally
i'm a very big believer in what i do
with drock like filming your day-to-day
is an incredible way to scale
content the other thing i did was i did
a ton of podcasts and shows that had
very small audiences just to be on the
receiving end of questions so that i
would have content
so literally dming
small podcasts and saying hey
you know if you'd like to interview me
and you know as you're evolving through
your careers that's a good get for a
small podcast so it's good for them but
it's also good for you because you can
post produce the creative
and q what's amazing about q a is the
questions take you to places you won't
take yourself
so those are some things to think about
i view that content is the oxygen
that creates awareness around what
you're doing
so to your point if you stop creating to
do something
you in essence are turning off the
oxygen of what you're doing so the
reason i have continuously content
created even though i've gotten
remarkably busier
in my time is because i agree with that
i think once you stop creating
you become less vulnerable oprah winfrey
businesses are not as impactful today as
they were a decade ago because she
doesn't have a show
that's just real life
and so
yeah i'm i'm a believer that at all
costs as a matter of fact one of my
biggest anxiety points professionally is
that because now befriends
is so successful in taking up my time
while i still have to run vayner vaynerx
the thing that you know
we only have so much time in the day the
biggest casualty
to the huge success that i have in nft
land is my content
i am definitely in a different output
place
i mean i went seven eight years without
putting out four pieces of content on my
instagram every day and now
i get two a day and that's like a big
day and
that adds up and so i'm i'm conscious of
that i think about that
[Music]